hello everyone welcome to simply learn
today we will be doing a machine
learning interactive quiz before we get
started i hope the screen is clearly
visible and the audio is fine
if there are any issues please type yes
do let us know in the chat section so
that we can resolve them
i see a lot of positive responses
let's wait for some time for others to
join us
great i think we can get started
hello everyone i am
from simply learn welcome to today's
quiz on machine learning we will be
starting with our quiz soon before which
will be take a small precap into the
world of machine learning and where the
world is moving forwards in regards to
it stay tuned until the end of the quiz
for a chance to win amazon vouchers
if you are among the top three winners
don't forget to send their screenshot
from your respective email id to youtube
contest at the rate did simplylearn.net
that being said let's learn a little bit
more about the state of machine learning
in 2022
machine learning is a subpart of
artificial intelligence broadly defined
as a machine's capability to mutate him
intelligent human behavior
like humans learn from their past and
acquire knowledge through experience
either directly or shared by others
machine acquired knowledge through
experience shared in the form of data
machine learning is becoming
increasingly important in our everyday
life
identification of trends and patterns
automation predicting of weather
predictive analysis and many other
applications utilize machine learning
machine learning is classified into four
parts supervise unsupervised
reinforcement learning and semi
supervised learning
machine learning is no longer a science
fiction concept there are 1.41 billion
industry that is already upgrading the
way we comprehend and use enormous
information for various uses
machine learning and ai have the
potential to disrupt and improve our
content process in almost every area of
society
from assisting cutting-edge cancer
research to assisting businesses and
tracking their inventory
knowingly or unknowingly machine
learning is playing a major role in our
day-to-day life here are some
applications of machine learning which
will improve how machine learning is
helping everyone all over the globe
we all use youtube netflix and facebook
in our daily life the machine learning
algorithms figures out the patterns of
what type of video move we watch and
does they provide a suggestion
accordingly
tesla is the one of the best companies
which manufactures self-driving cars
using electric solar and integrated
renewable energy solutions
cars by tesla are already making their
way to the market and are ready to show
the world power of ai and machine
learning
another application of machine learning
is speech recognition
we all aware of voice assistance like by
siri
apple
cortana by microsoft and alexa by amazon
these assistant translate is piece to
text and use machine learning to provide
their results
machine learning is also used in medical
sector to determine various diseases
with the help of machine learning the
patterns and symptoms of diseases can be
easily diagnosed
weather forecasting and financial
forecasting are other applications of
machine learning in the future outcomes
are predicted using historical data it
involves the use of statical modeling
data mining techniques and machine
learning for predictions
if you are prepared to infuse machine
learning into your corporate strategy
and offer specialized experiences check
out simply learn's machine learning
certification course which covers all
the concept of machine learning while
following a flexible schedule to suit
your needs
it covers the types of machine learning
among
with the time series modeling and
practice project to solidify your
foundation before and the certificate
you can also offer the free skill of
courses which provides you the basic
knowledge of machine learning
with just 6 hours of training and
certification boot with it
you can get ready to tackle your first
ml experience with panic
with the salaries of machine learning
trained professionals projected to grow
by 38 percent
the time is ripe up to obscure yourself
with the simply learn and accelerate
your career today
to take part in the quiz it is highly
recommended to use your mobile phone to
visit the website www.mandy.com
and use the code
48118784 or being shown on this screen
now
you can also use a different tab on your
browser to take part in the quiz but our
live stream will be broadcasting the
result as soon as the answers are given
by the participant so
it is beneficial to have both screen
visible at the same time
once you open the link and input the
code just wait for the quiz to start and
be ready to answer the question the
faster you you respond the more and more
it points you on so
think quickly and click quickly
let's wait two
new folks to join
i am repeating again to take part in the
quiz it is highly recommended to use
your mobile phone to visit the website
www.mandy.com and use the code
481187
or being shown on the screen now
you can also use a different tab on your
browser to take part in the quiz but our
live stream will be broadcasting the
result as soon as the answers are given
by the participants
so it is beneficial to have both screen
visible at the same time
once you open the link and input the
code
just wait for the quiz to start and be
ready to answers the question the faster
you respond the more and more points you
want so
think quickly and click quickly
let's wait for one more minute
so i'm repeating again to take part in
the quiz it is highly recommended to use
your mobile phone or visit the website
www.mandy.com
and use the code
48118784 or being shown on the screen
now
you can also use a different tab on your
browser to take part in the quiz but our
live stream will be broadcasting the
result as soon as the answers are given
by the participants so it is beneficial
to have both screen visible at the same
time
once you open the link and input the
code just wait for the quiz to start and
be ready to answer the questions
the faster you respond the more and more
points you want so
think quickly and click quickly
let's wait for one minute more
remember that the faster you respond the
more and more points you want so think
quickly and click quickly
don't use chat section to respond the
answers
the faster you respond the more and more
points you want so think quickly and
click quickly
so now we have enough folks to
play this quiz let's get this party
started
answer fast to get more points
so question one is what is machine
learning
option one
the selective acquisition of knowledge
through the use of computer programs
option b selective knowledge acquisition
through the use of manual programs
option c
the autonomous acquisition of knowledge
through the use of computer programs
option d autonomous knowledge
acquisition through the use of manual
programs you have five second more
time server
let's move on the leaderboard and see
the positioning of the forks
so your bras they is leading the
scoreboard now
the simulation of human intelligence
functions by machine particularly
computer system is known as artificial
intelligence expert system natural
language processing speech recognition
and machine vision are some example of
specific mlx application
so let's move on to the next question
answer fast to get more points remember
that
so question two is who is the father of
machine learning
i am repeating who is the father of
machine learning
option a joffrey hill
option b geoffrey
option c joffrey average hinton and
option d none of the above
15 seconds more
five second remaining
and the time zone
let's see
and you just gave the right answers
still leading the board
on december 6 1947 jobley everest hinton
was born he is a computer scientist and
cognitive psychologist best known for
his work on artificial neutral network
he has split his time between google and
the university of toronto since 2013
joffrey average hinton has been dubbed
the fatherhood machine
and the ai numerous times
so let's move to the third question
remember that the answer passed to get
more and more points
the third question is machine learning
is a subset of
option a
data learning option b
artificial intelligence option c
deep learning option d
none of the above
i am repeating again
machine learning is a subset of
data learning artificial intelligence
deep learning and none of the above
five seconds more to go
and the time zone
15 folks gave the correct answer
so
the simulation of human intelligence
functions by machines particularly
computer system is known as artificial
intelligence expert system natural
language processing space recognition
and the machine visions are some
examples of specific ai application
let's move on the leaderboard and see
the positioning of the folks
day is still leading the board
and following by anirudh and funny
so let's move to the next question
remember this guys answer pass to get
more and more points
so the fourth question is
how many types of machine learning
techniques
option a
three
option b 4
option c 5
option c 6
i'm repeating a main how many types of
machine learning techniques
10 second modes to go
five seconds small
time sub
so 12 folks are given the correct answer
so there are four types of machine
learning
which are supervised learning
unsupervised learning reinforcement
learning semi supervised learning
supervised learning in the machine is
trained with the help of label data with
external guidance this machine learning
model is a small preparation data set to
work with
so let's move to on the leaderboard and
see positioning of the forks
still leading the board and following by
anirudh and munaza so i want
new names guys so click fast to and fast
so let's move to the next question
and the fifth question is
remember this point answer pass to get
more and more points the fifth question
is machine learning algorithms generate
a model based on sample of data known as
option a training data
option b transfer data
option c training data
option d none of the above
15 seconds more
i'm repeating again machine learning
algorithms generate a model based on
samples of data known as
hurry up guys five second more
yeah time's up
15 4 gave the correct answer
so
machine learning algorithm construct a
model from sample data which is referred
to as training data training data is the
data used to train an algorithm or
machine learning model to operate the
outcomes you wanted to predict
test data is used to assess the
performance of algorithm used to train
the machines such as accuracy or
efficiency
so let's move on the leaderboard and see
the positioning of the people
so who is leading the boat
is still leading the board and following
by anirudh and following by munaza
so big byte gave the fastest answer
so let's move to the next question
so question number six this
guys remember this thing answer fast to
get more and more points so question six
is both supervised learning and
unsupervised learning requires at least
one
input attribute
sorry about that guys there is some
internet connections you
so we will move to the next question
answer fast to get more and more points
with machine learning is a field of ai
consisting of learning algorithms
the options are consist executing some
task
option b over time with experience
option c improved their performance
and option d is all of the above
15 seconds more
which machine learning is a field of ai
consisting of learning algorithms
three
two one and time sub
nine people gave the correct answer
so
option d all of the options are correct
because with the aid of machine learning
without being explicitly programmed
software programs can predict outcomes
more accurately it also
helps in the development of new products
and provides businesses with a picture
of consumer behavior trends and
operational business patterns
so let's move on the leaderboard and see
the positions
so
this time anil
gave the fastest answer and anirudh is
leading the board and following by
ubrazi and mozart
so let's move to the next question
i want new faces guys
click fast to unfast
and answer pass to get more and more
points come on
so question number eight is which is
widely used and effective machine
learning algorithm based on the idea of
badging
option a regression
option b
classification option c decision tree
option d
random forest i am repeating again
which is a widely used and effective
machine learning algorithm based on the
idea of badging
five second more to go
hurry up guys
times up
ten folks gave the correct answer
so
random forest is a type of supervised
machine learning algorithm that is
commonly used in classification and
regression problem it constructs
decision trees from various samples and
uses their majority board for
classification and average of regression
the random forex algorithm is the
capability to deal with the sets of data
with both continuous and categorical
variables
such as in regression and classification
is among its most important
characteristic it outperforms their
classification algorithms
so let's see the leaderboard who is
winning
so this time gibbs gave the fastest
answer and still anirudh is leading the
board
so come on big bites shalini ashes
himanshu sumangal come on come on guys i
want new faces
so
let's move to the next question
so question number nine is
answer pass to get more and more points
i'm repeating again answer fast to get
more and more point guys so question
number nine is which machine learning
techniques helps in detecting the
outliers in data
option a numbers of clusters
option b classification option c anomaly
detection and all of the above
come on guys 10 seconds more to go
come on
area five seconds left
and the time's up
so this time tell people's gave the
correct answers
so anomaly detection is a machine
learning technique that is in the
detection of outliers in the data the
process of identifying data points in
the data that do not fit the expected
patterns is known as anomaly detection
it can be used to solve a variety of
problems including fraud detection
medical diagnosis and so on machine
learning methods enables the automation
and enhancement of anonymity detection
particularly when large data sets are
involved
so let's move to the leaderboard
and see the positionings of the folks
like who is leading
so this time
who gave the correct answer
who is leading
so anirudh gave the fastest answer and
is still leading
followed by gibbs and munaza and funny
karan
so big bite shalini rajkumar b come on
click fast on fast
so moving to the next questions
so remember this point guys
remember this answer pass to get more
and more points remember this thing only
what does k stand for in k mean
algorithm i am repeating again what does
km stand for in k means algorithm option
a numbers of clusters option b
number of data option c number of
attributes and option d is number of
alterations
i am repeating again what does k stand
for in k means algorithms
five seconds left
hurry up guys
time's up
let's see
three people gave the correct answer
so the answer is number of iterations
k means clustering is an unsupervised
learning algorithm that divides an
unlabeled data set into a cluster
k refers to the number of predefined
grouping that must be formed during the
process for example if k equals to 2 2
cluster will be created if k equals to 3
c cluster will be created and so on
k n allows us to group the data into
different groups and provides convenient
method for discovering the categories of
the groups in the unlabeled data set
without the need of training
so let's move to the leaderboard
and see who is leading the board
so
and gives
gave the correct answer and i need this
gave the fastest answer
so
shalini big bite amit sumangal come on
guys click fast so please remember that
only the answers provided on the
mantimeter platform will be applicable
for the amazon voucher do visit
mentee.com and use the code 4811
to take part i am repeating again please
remember that the answer provided on the
mentimeter platform will be applicable
for the amazon vouchers do visit
mandy.com and use the code 48118784
to take part
so let's move to the next question
so question number 11 is
answer fast to get more and more points
so question number 11 is what is the
other name for an output attribute
i'm repeating again what is the other
name for an output attribute
option a predictive variable
option b estimated variable option d
dependent variable and option d
independent variable
i am repeating again the question what
is the other name for an output
attribute
five second left guys come on come on
hurry up
time's up
so
four folks gave the correct answers
so
independent variables is the other name
for an output variable
independent variables are the variables
used in the model to explain or predict
changes in the dependent variable
the name explains their role in statical
analysis
these variables are unrelated in the
context independent means that they
stand alone and the affected by the
other variables in the model
the researchers are not interested in
discovering what caused the independent
variable to change
so let's move to the leaderboard and see
who is
winning who gave the fastest answer
so
i guess the new this is still leading
the board
amit gave the parcel answer cool this
time cool and gibbs
and mundus on second and third points
come on guys i need new names new names
in the leaderboard please
so let's move to the next question and
next question is
question number 12
is
remember this point answer pass to get
more and more points guys answer passed
so number 12 is which is not a machine
learning algorithm
this is the basic one which is not a
machine learning algorithm
svg option b svm option c random forest
and option d is all of the above
i i'm repeating again which is not a
machine learning algorithms
this is the simplest one the basic
question of machine learning can be
five seconds left guys hurry up
and the time's up
oh i see
13 people gave the correct answers
so scalable vector graph svg is not a
machine learning algorithms an xml based
vector picture format called scalable
vector graphs is used to define two
dimensional graphics and supports motion
and interactivity
the worldwide web association
has been working on the svg standard
as an open platform since 1999.
so let's move to the leaderboard and see
who is leading the board
so
anez is still leading the board
amit gave the fastest answer
and gibbs and munaza in second and
hurry up guys
answer pass click fast to answer first
so i am repeating again one more time
please remember that only the answer
provided on the mantimeter platform will
be applicable for the amazon voucher do
visit mandy.com and use the code
48118784 to take part
so our next question is
question number 13
so guys answer pass to get more and more
points
go to mandybug.com so answer question 13
is what is the disadvantage of decision
trees
option a factor analysis
option b decision trees and robust two
outliers option c decision trees and
prone to be overfit
option d is all of the above
this is the basic question
what is the disadvantage of decision
trees
10 seconds left guys
five second more to go
and the time's up
let's see how many people gave the
correct answer
eight eight people gave the correct
answers so
the disadvantage of decision tree is a
decision trees are prone to overfit
overfitting is a common in decision
trees
especially when the tree is particularly
deep
this is due to the amount of specificity
we examine
which result in a smaller sample of
events that need the previous assumption
this small sample size may lead to
erroneous conclusions
so let's move to the leaderboard and see
who is leading the board
so after 13 questions
anirudh is still leading the board
come on you raj javaland rajkumar
and amit gave the fastest answer
so
come on guys
answer get to more form and more points
so moving next question
so question number 14 is
and some pass to get more and more
points guys come on so question number
14 is how may can deal with missing or
corrupted data in our data set i'm
repeating again how can you deal with
the missing or corrupted data set in our
data
so question number is drop missing rows
or columns
question number b
assign a unique category to missing
values
option c
so let's move
in this case
amit gave the fastest answer and i
needed this leading the board
and
rajkumar b and sumang love come on guys
so all of the options are correct
if the majority of the data for our
columns or row is missing
simply delete them the aggregated value
is based on the remaining values in the
column
and the received number is placed in the
empty spot
categorical features have multiple
possible values which allows us to
create a new category for the missing
values so i am repeating again please
remember that only the answer provided
on the mendimeter platform will be
applicable for the amazon vouchers so do
visit mandy.com and use the code
eight 48118784 to take part
so moving to the next question
question number fifteen
and
i will say answer pass to get more and
more point guys hurry up
so question number 15 is which of the
followings are the most widely used
metrics and tools to assess our
classification model
option a confusion matrix option b
cost sensitivity accuracy caution c
the area under the roc curve and option
d all of the above
10 seconds more guys come on hurry up
repeating again which of the followings
are the most widely used metrics and
tools to assess our classification
models
so everyone has voted so
five people gave the correct answers
good one
so area under the roc curve confusion
matrix and cost sensitive across it
when classification models make
prediction on the test data a confusion
matrix evaluates their performance and
tell us how good our classification
model is
cost sensitive learning is a branch of
machine learning that deals with
classification problems where the cost
of misclassification are not equal
many disciplines including medicine
engineering transportation and finance
have cause sensitive problems
aoc is a metrics that aggregate
performance across all classification
threshold
auc can be defined as the likelihood
that a random positive example will be
ranked higher than a random negative
example by the model
so this is why all the three options
mentioned are the correct
so let's see the leaderboard and who is
leading the board
so
i guess
okay i need is still leading the board
there is a race between anirudh and
gibbs so amit gave the fastest answer
so
okay let's move to the next question
which is
so question number 16
and
answer fast to get more and more point
guys
question number 16 is
it is the approach of the basic
algorithms for decision tree induction
and the options are
option is greedy option b module
function
option c procedural and option d step by
step
i am repeating again which is the
approach of the basic algorithms for
decision tree induction
10 seconds left
come on guys hurry up
five seconds left
and the time
so
six folks gave the correct answers
so
greedy is the approach of basic
algorithms for decision tree induction
during huffman coding a greedy algorithm
is used to build a huffman tree and find
an optimal solution
greedy algorithms are commonly used in
decision free learning
but they are not guaranteed to find the
optimal solution
the id three algorithms for decision
tree construction is a popular examples
of such an algorithm
so let's see the leaderboard
who is leading the board
this time another
gave the wrong answer and i guess
now yes gibbs is leading the board
followed by android and funny karan
amit was the fastest who gave the answer
and
following by munaza and samantha
so
let's move to the next question
question number 17
so
[Music]
answer pass to get more and more points
guys come on hurry up so question number
17 is where base rules can be used
so this is the basic question where base
rule can be used
option a solving queries
option b increasing complexity
option d decreasing complexity and
option d is answering probabilistic
query
i am repeating again where base rule can
be used
you have 10 seconds left
have second more guys come on hurry up
so eight fours gave the correct answers
which is answering a probabilistic query
so the base rule can be used to answer
the probabilistic query the name based
classifier is a simple and effective
classification algorithm that aids in
the development of fast machine learning
models
that can make accurate predictions
it is a probabilistic classifier which
means it predicts
based on an object probability so let's
see who is leading the board
so there is a fight going between
anirudh and gibbs come on guys hurry up
click fast
okay gibbs gave the fastest answer
so gibbs is leading the board and
followed by anirudh and amit
so come on ashish himanshu rajkumar
funny
click fast so
there is a gentle reminder we keep
hosting quizzes based on different
technologies every week
so if you want to stay updated with the
latest news regarding these events and
stay up to date with the latest trends
so do subscribe to our channel and hit
the bell icon to be updated
so
let's move to the next question which is
question number 18
so on some parts to get more and more
points guys come on hurry up i need new
names
so question number 18 is which of the
following methods do we use to point the
best fit line for data in linear
regression
option a
least square method option b
maximum likelihood option c logarithmic
loss option d is both a and b
i am repeating again which of the
following methods do we use to find the
best fit line for the data in linear
regression
come on guys aria five second left come
on
so time's up let's see who gave the
correct answers
five folks gave the correct answers
so
least required execution analysis is a
popular regression analysis method for
estimating unknown parameters by
constructing a model that minimizes the
sum of squared errors between observed
and predicted data it is essentially one
of the most widely used curve fitting
methods that work by minimizing the sum
of squared errors to the greatest extent
possible
it assists you in determining the best
fit line based on your data points
so let's see who is leading the board
i hope i will see the new faces
okay now good munaja
which i gave the fastest answers
so this time gabe sunny wrote amit
failed to give the correct answer so no
issues let's move to the next question
so question number 19 is
i'm repeating again guys answer fast to
get more and more points
come on the most common issue when using
machine learning is the basic one the
most common issue when using machine
learning is
option a poor data quality
option b inadequate infrastructure
option c lack of skilled resources
option d is none of the above i am
repeating again the most common issue
when using machine learning is
come on guys 10 seconds left come on